DANA PERINO AND GREG GUTFELD.
THIS IS "THE FIVE."
PRESIDENT TRUMP UNLOADING ON
NANCY PELOSI, JOE BIDEN AND
OTHERS DURING A FIERY SHOWDOWN
WITH THE MEDIA.
IF HE'S READY TO SEND A POLICY A
LETTER DARING HER TO PUT
DEMOCRATS ON RECORD BY HOLDING A
VOTE.
>> President Trump: THIS IS
THE GREATEST WITCH HUNT IN THE
HISTORY OF OUR COUNTRY.
SO THE DEMOCRATS UNFORTUNATELY
HAVE THE VOTE.
IF THEY COULD DEVOTE VERY EASILY
EVEN THOUGH MOST OF THEM, MANY
OF THEM DON'T BELIEVE THEY
SHOULD DO IT.
AND THEY ARE REAL LEADERS, AOC
PLUS THREE.
THAT'S THE REAL LEADERS.
I REALLY BELIEVE THAT THEY WILL
PAY A TREMENDOUS PRICE OF THE
POLLS.
>> Jesse: TRUMP IS, THE
PRESIDENT IS CALLING OUT WHAT HE
SAYS A SERIOUS CORRUPTION FROM
SLEEPY JOE AND HIS SON.
>> President Trump: I WAS
INVESTIGATED.
WHAT I SAW BIDEN DO WITH HIS
SON, HE IS PILLAGING THESE
COUNTRIES AND HE'S HURTING US.
WE WANT TO INVESTIGATE ANYTHING
HAVING TO DO WITH CORRUPTION.
I'M ONLY INTERESTED IN
CORRUPTION.
I DON'T CARE ABOUT POLITICS.
I DON'T CARE ABOUT BIDEN'S
POLITICS.
I'VE WATCHED BIDEN OVER THE
YEARS AND BIDEN IS NOT THE
BRIGHTEST PERSON.
I NEVER THOUGHT HE WAS GOING TO
WIN, HE GOT TAKEN OFF OF THE
GARBAGE HEAP BY OBAMA.
>> Jesse: A MEMBER OF THE
SQUAD IS THREATENING TO THROW
TRUMP OFFICIALS IN PRISON.
>> WHAT HAPPENS WHEN THEY DON'T
COMPLY?
THIS IS THE FIRST TIME WE'VE
EVER HAD A SITUATION LIKE THIS
SO WE ARE TRYING TO FIGURE OUT,
NO JOKE.
IS IT THE D.C. POLICE THAT GOES
AGAINST THEM?
NO.
>> WE REMEMBERED DANA, SHE WAS
THE ONE IN THE BEGINNING WHO
SAID WE HAVE TO IMPEACH THE
MOTHER F.
AND NOW SHE WANTS TO LOCK HIM U
UP.
>> Dana: IF THAT'S NOT HOW ANY
OF THIS WORKS.
IT WAS INTERESTING TO SEE SOME
OF THESE TOWN HALLS AND HEARING
THEM GET A LITTLE BIT AHEAD OF
THEMSELVES AND I IMAGINE THAT
NANCY PELOSI, I WAS WANTING TO
BE A VERY MEASURED AND
THOUGHTFUL PERSON, SHE'S THE
PRAYERFUL ONE, SHE HAS ALL THOSE
DEMOCRATS OUT HERE SAYING THINGS
LIKE, WE WANT TO -- WHATEVER
MAXINE WATERS SAID IT.
I CAN'T REMEMBER THAT ONE.
THE TRUMPS WHITE HOUSE IS TRYING
TO CONVINCE THE AMERICAN PEOPLE
THAT THE DEMOCRATS ARE DOING
EVERYTHING POLITICAL AND, THAT'S
WORKING IN THEIR FAVOR IN A LOT
OF WAYS, ESPECIALLY WHEN YOU
HAVE THE CHAIRMAN OF THE
INTELLIGENCE COMMITTEE
ADAM SCHIFF GETTING FOR
PINOCCHIO'S FROM
"THE WASHINGTON POST" FOR NOT
BEING FULLY FORTHCOMING ABOUT
THE CONTACT WITH THE
WHISTLE-BLOWER BEFORE THE
COMPLAINT WAS FILED.
I THINK THE WHITE HOUSE HAS SOME
RESETTING TO DO AS WELL.
THE MORE THEY TALK ABOUT THIS,
THE REASON THEY AREN'T ABLE TO
STAY ON THAT.
THE STOCK MARKET IS HAVING A
LITTLE BIT OF RESURGENCE.
THE HOUSE ISN'T A QUESTION.
THE SENATE, THERE IS VERY LITTLE
CHANCE, LIKE MAYBE ZERO
MINUSCULE CHANCE THAT THE
REPUBLICANS WHATEVER JOIN THE
DEMOCRATS IN THIS EFFORT.
SO NOW IT'S IN THE COURT OF
PUBLIC OPINION.
IF I WERE IN THE WHITE HOUSE I
WOULD RESET A LITTLE BIT OVER
THE WEEKEND.
>> Jesse: THAT SHOULD BE THE
CORE TO THE STRATEGY.
IT'S THE DO-NOTHING DEMOCRATS ON
THE PARTISAN INSIDE WITCH HUNT.
THE PRESIDENT ALSO LISTED SOME
PINOCCHIO'S.
LET'S LISTEN.
>> President Trump: I HEARD
ADAM SCHIFF GOT FOR PINOCCHIO'S.
THAT'S GOOD, HE SHOULD HAVE
GOTTEN THEM FOUR AND A HALF
YEARS AGO.
WHEN I SPEAK TO FOREIGN LEADERS
I SPEAK IN AN APPROPRIATE WAY.
IF YOU NOTICE, THEY DON'T
MENTION THE CALL THAT I HAD WITH
THE PRESIDENT OF UKRAINE.
THEY DON'T MENTION THAT.
BECAUSE IT WAS SO GOOD.
THE ONLY TIME THEY MENTIONED IT
WAS WHEN ADAM SCHIFF MADE IT UP.
TALK ABOUT PINOCCHIO'S, THAT
SHOULD GET TEN PINOCCHIO'S.
>> THAT'S QUITE A FEW.
ONE, DO YOU REGRET THAT
ADAM SCHIFF WASN'T HONEST WHEN
HE DIDN'T TELL EVERYBODY, EVEN
PEOPLE IN HIS COMMITTEE THAT HE
MET WITH THE WHISTLE-BLOWER
BEFORE?
>> Juan: HE DIDN'T, PEOPLE ON
HIS STAFF DID.
HE HAD EVERY OPPORTUNITY TO SAY,
WHAT I MEANT TO SAY WAS THEY
DIDN'T MEET WITH ME OR WITH THE
PANEL OR THE COMMITTEE BUT THEY
MET WITH COMMITTEE STAFF.
SO I THINK HE WAS PROPERLY
CHASTENED, I THINK YOU MADE A
MISTAKE AND I THINK HE MADE A
MISTAKE WITH THE PARITY.
I UNDERSTAND IT WAS JUST
SUMMARIZING WHAT THE PRESIDENT
HAD TO SAY BUT IT WAS RIGHT
THERE IN FRONT OF YOU.
MY FEELING AS THOUGH IT'S VERY
FUNNY TO HEAR THE PRESIDENT SAY,
THIS IS ALL ABOUT THE
CORRUPTION.
I'M NOT CONCERNED ABOUT
POLITICS.
THE ONLY TIME I HEAR HIM
SCREAMING ABOUT THE UKRAINIANS
OR THE RUSSIANS OR ANYONE ELSE,
IT'S JOE BIDEN OR
HILLARY CLINTON.
I'VE NOT HEARD ANYBODY ELSE
CITED BY PRESIDENT TRUMP WITH
REGARD TO CORRUPTION.
SO I THINK THIS IS HIGHLY --
>> Jesse: HE HASN'T MENTIONED
CORRUPTION IN CHINA AND THE
U.N., MEXICO -- CENTRAL AMERICA,
LOTS OF CORRUPT NATIONS OUT
THERE.
HOW DO YOU SEE THIS UNFOLDING?
>> EVERYONE LIKES TO ACT LIKE
PRESIDENT TRUMP IS UNHINGED BUT
THAT WAS BRILLIANT POLITICAL
MESSAGING.
AND MORE AND MORE, JOE BIDEN
FROM THE DEMOCRAT PERSPECTIVE
LOOKS EXPENDABLE.
HE IS DISPOSABLE.
HE IS POLITICAL PICNIC CUTLERY,
IF YOU WILL.
THEY HATE TRUMP MORE THAN THEY
LIKE JOE BIDEN CLEARLY.
AND IT'S GOING TO MEAN A DRIP,
DRIP, DROP, DROP, ABOUT HUNTER
BIDEN COMING OUT OF THE UKRAINE.
IT'S OBVIOUS INFLUENCE, FOR THE
VICE PRESIDENT KNEW ABOUT IT OR
NOT AND IT SMELLS LIKE PAY TO
PLAY.
THAT WILL BE THE MESSAGING.
BIDEN ALREADY HAD AN REPUTATION
FOR BEING UNDISCIPLINED AND
LOUSY AT FUND-RAISING.
HE STILL LOUSY AT FUND-RAISING
AND HE'S STILL RUSTY AND
UNFOCUSED AND HE REPRESENTS
EVERYTHING THAT THE VERY
LEFT-WING PARTY HATES.
I THINK HE'S A GONER AND HE IS
RARELY LEADING IN THE NATIONAL
POLL.
>> Jesse: THEY ARE CITING
DEVASTATING CHARACTERIZATIONS OF
THE FUND-RAISING HALL BY OTHER
DEMOCRATS IN THE PARTY.
HE'S ACTUALLY LOST MOMENTUM FROM
THE FIRST AND SECOND QUARTER
HERE, BEING OUTRAGED NOT ONLY BY
SANDERS AND WARREN, BUT BY
BOOTED JUDGE.
AND THAT'S NOT GOOD.
>> Greg: NO IT'S NOT, JESSE,
NO IT'S NOT.
IT WASN'T LONG AGO THAT THE DEMS
CARED SO MUCH ABOUT CORRUPTION
AND COLLUSION, BUT NOT WHEN
TRUMP WANTS TO PURSUE
CORRUPTION.
SO I TELL THEM TO FP FAU.
DO YOU KNOW THAT STANDS FOR?
SILENCE A FALSE UKULELE.
I HAVE A THEORY ON WHY TRUMP IS
EXPRESSING ANGER.
BECAUSE I BELIEVE HE DOES WANT
JOE BIDEN, IT'S NOT A POLITICAL
THING BUT A CORRUPTION THING.
HE WANTS TO GO UP AGAINST
JOE BIDEN BECAUSE JOE BIDEN IS
SHAKY.
HE'S LIKE AN IKEA DRESSER.
>> THAT YOU PUT TOGETHER
YOURSELF.
>> Greg: EXACTLY.
YOU ARE EITHER ON ONE SIDE OR
THE OTHER AND I THINK THAT'S
WHAT'S UPSETTING TRUMP, ONCE A
PRIVATE CITIZEN, THERE WERE NO
SIDES TO HIM.
THERE WERE JUST PEOPLE YOU PAID.
HE GAVE DONATIONS TO REPUBLICANS
AND NOW HE HAS FOUND HIMSELF IN
THIS TWO-SIDED PRISON.
HE IS LIKE WATCHING PEOPLE CALL
HIM POLITICAL WHO CREATED THE
POLITICAL ENVIRONMENT WELL
BEFORE HE GOT THERE AND WHILE HE
IS THERE.
SO THINK ABOUT THIS.
A GUY WHO HAS NEVER BEEN
POLITICAL WHO IS BASICALLY CEO
FOR THE COUNTRY WHETHER YOU LIKE
IT OR NOT.
HE'S GOT FULL EMPLOYMENT, HE'S
GOT PRISON REFORM AND DRUG
REFORM, TRADE RESETS WHETHER YOU
LIKE IT OR NOT.
A LOT OF THIS STUFF DOESN'T LAND
ON ONE SIDE, IT'S ON EVERY SIDE.
YOU COULD BE A LEFTY AND LIKE
PRISON REFORM.
YOU COULD BE A RIGHTY AND, THE
WARS, LIBERTARIANS LOVE THIS
GUY.
SO WHEN YOU SEE SOMEONE WHO IS
ANGRY, HE'S ANGRY THAT THERE IS
A SIDE GOING AGAINST HIM AND
HE'S REALIZED THAT ACHIEVEMENT
AND THAT THESE ACHIEVEMENTS ARE
NO MATCH FOR THE POLITICAL PARTY
MARRIED TO THE MEDIA.
HE'S GETTING ALL THE STUFF DONE
BUT NOBODY CARES.
>> Juan: WHAT YOU JUST SAID
WAS IT'S ALL ABOUT HIM.
THERE IS NO PARTY, IT'S A PARTY
OF TRUMP.
IT WAS PEACE AND PROSPEROUS
BEFORE BUT I WILL TELL YOU WHAT
STRIKES ME, TODAY THE DEMOCRATS
HAD THE VOTES TO IMPEACH HIM.
TO ME THIS WAS AN IMPORTANT
THING TO SAY BECAUSE HE'S
SAYING, THAT'S WHAT'S GOING TO
HAPPEN.
AND MY SENSE IS, THE
PERSUADABLE'S.
HE WANTS TO WIN IN A COURT OF
PUBLIC OPINION.
WHICH HE MIGHT.
THAT MIGHT BE WHY HE IS GOING
AFTER ADAM SCHIFF.
BUT, YOU HAVE A LITANY OF
ACHIEVEMENTS AND YOU REALIZE
THAT THIS TUG-OF-WAR IS ANYTHING
BUT.
AND THIS IS ALL POLITICAL.
IF IT DOESN'T MATTER WHO IS IN
CHARGE.
IT HAPPENED TO OBAMA, IT
HAPPENED TO CLINTON, AND HAVE
BEEN TO REAGAN AND IT HAPPENED
TO TRUMP.
>> HE WANTS WHAT'S BEST FOR THE
AMERICAN PEOPLE.